[Music]
there are few things better than finding
out that your favorite Disney characters
share the same family tree with this in
mind
Disney planted Easter eggs in every
single one of their movies watch until
the end to find out which Disney
character is Jane's great-grandmother
first time at the things don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up so are you ready
to find out which Disney characters
share the same DNA healthy baby girl a
princess was born with beautiful golden
hair Ariel and Hercules it's hard to
believe that Ariel could be related to
any member of the Disney family because
well she's a mermaid for crying out loud
I just don't see things the way he does
I don't see how wonderful things could
be bad regardless of this it looks like
the little mermaids got a lot more to
our family tree than meets the eye
whether Disney planned for Ariel and
Hercules to be cousins is up for debate
but we can't deny their heritage given
the facts are you up to date with your
Greek mythology well we weren't either
until we got our hands on this tidbit of
information as many of you know
Hercules is the son of the almighty Zeus
and Zeus has more than a few siblings to
account for well it looks like one of
them is none other than Triton who
happens to be Ariel's father both Triton
and Zeus are the sons of Poseidon making
Ariel and Hercules first cousins where
one cousin was born high up in the sky
the other was born in the deepest
corners of the sea this makes them polar
opposites that doesn't mean that they
can't find common ground
after all they both ended up falling in
love with humans and living amongst them
on the mainland Elsa Anna and Rapunzel
when you think about it it makes total
sense that Disney would want to create a
universe that welcomes each and every
one of their characters so it's not too
surprising to find out that some royal
families share common members in 2010 we
fell in love with the sweet and innocent
Rapunzel and only then will I return
your satchel to you
that is my deal and watched with awe as
she bravely chased after her dreams
after gaining her life back and falling
in love with Eugene the two love bugs
were invited to a special coronation
ceremony so wanting to meet her cousins
for the first time Rapunzel sailed to
arendelle with Eugene at her side while
three years might have passed before
Rapunzel went to arendelle she seemed
more than happy to congratulate Elsa on
her coronation Anna and Elsa are first
cousins with Rapunzel and they're more
alike than you would believe this is
especially true when you take Elsa and
Rapunzel into consideration both these
cousins are blonde and have magical
powers on top of that they both know
what it feels like to be locked away for
years at a time
are you surprised to find out that these
princesses are part of the same royal
family well if you are make sure to
strap on your seat belt because this is
the least big surprise that's coming
your way
Ariel and the unnamed mermaid there's a
lot about Ariel that we don't know and
thankfully Disney saw fit to give us the
inside scoop by releasing The Little
Mermaid
Ariel's beginning in this film we
finally get the answer to one long-lost
question who is Ariel's mother our song
[Music]
Queen Athena was a kind and just ruler
however her life came to an abrupt end
when pirates ransacked the sandy shores
of the mermaid lagoon while there's no
doubt in our mind that this version of
Queen Athena is strong and true we
believe that there's another version of
her out there do you remember seeing
mermaids in Peter Pan well so do we and
after examining the scene a little more
we can't help but notice a resemblance
between Ariel and a certain redheaded
mermaid while Disney has yet to confirm
this theory
it isn't unlike done to hide Easter eggs
in their movies and then refuse to
comment on their existence Disney's
Peter Pan came out in 1953 and The
Little Mermaid followed 36 years later
while this timeline would prevent Queen
Athena from being her young and fertile
self there's one factor to consider you
don't age when your Neverland so
technically the unnamed mermaid could
have lived in Neverland for decades
before choosing to marry King Triton
Emily and Andy Toy Story might be
considered as a Pixar movie but in the
end it was released by Walt Disney
Pictures so we've decided to include
this film on our list because frankly
this information is too juicy to miss we
all know who Andy is he loves his toys
respects his mom and never forgets about
his friends but how much do we know
about his mother Andy's mom goes by the
name of Miss Davis which makes us think
that Disney purposely withheld her first
name this sneaky act might have been
overlooked for a long time but the truth
is about to come to life Andy's mom made
it clear that woody has been in her
family for decades which makes us think
that she used to play with him when she
was a kid in Toy Story 2 we got to take
a look at Jesse's backstory which placed
her under the care of a little girl
named Emily during this scene we see
Jessie sitting on a bed with a
human-sized replica of her cowgirl hat
perched next to her when you take a
closer look you'll see that this hat is
the same one
that Andy wears throughout the Toy Story
movies so basically this is all the
proof we need to put two and two
together so in other words Andy and
Emily are mother and son and she
eventually passes down all her antique
toys to him Elsa Anna and Tarzan every
Disney movie starts with a significant
loss which isn't always the easiest
thing to handle for this reason many of
us have stricken Bambi from the
collection seeing as it's impossible to
get past the first 10 minutes of the
film although movies like frozen also
begin with a freak accident
their tone makes it easier to get hooked
from the get-go as many of you know Elsa
and Anna lost both of their parents when
they were young girls their mom and dad
sailed off to sea but never reached
their destination nor did they ever
return to arendelle so in other words
they were proclaimed as goners and never
seen or heard from again
well it turns out that King Agner and
Queen a Doudna didn't sink along with
their ship instead they wound up on a
deserted island where they gave birth to
their son
Tarzan after being attacked by a leopard
Tarzan's parents were forced to leave
this world and let their infant fend for
himself luckily a nurturing gorilla
found the young bundle of joy and raised
him as her own despite never knowing
about his family Tarzan is indeed a
prince while we'd love to see Elsa Anna
and Tarzan reunite we don't see how this
would be possible but hey who knows what
the future holds Snow White and the
Queen we all know who Snow White is
she's a lovely 14 year old girl with
skin as white as snow this Disney
character first got attention in 1937
when the film Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs came out while Disney reinvented
the fairy tale to cater to their
audience the original Snow White story
had some significant differences for
starters the Evil Queen and Snow White
are actually related by blood well
Disney made it look as though the Evil
Queen was Snow White's stepmom she was
initially her birth mother in the
Grimm's fairy tale but Queen realizes
that her daughter is becoming
are beautiful than she ever was which
causes her to hire an assassin to murder
her only child despite her many attempts
to become the fairest of them all the
queen is never able to obtain this title
again while many of us were led to
believe that Snow White's mother passed
away when she was young it seems like
mother dearest had been watching over
her all along Moana and taffy tea may be
hard to believe that mallanna and taffy
tea share the same blood and this is
because defeat II is more of an Islander
than anything this goddess has the power
to create life which would make every
single human in the Moana film her child
after all without her magic the world
would solely be populated by oceans
after creating millions of islands to
feed he was finally able to rest sadly
it didn't take long for selfish people
to attempt to steal her heart after
being robbed of her love and innocence
defeat he transformed into tika a
fire-breathing lava monster who spreads
disease into the oceans knowing that her
heart needed to be restored the ocean
elected a baby named Moana with the task
so why would the seed do such a thing
well we believe that it's because Moana
is a descendant of taffy tea and that
only a kindred spirit could return her
heart without getting corrupted along
the way well this theory may seem absurd
there's a reason why Moana and taffy tea
look like the same person and it's
because they are in a way Maui's actions
cost mallanna's heart to get stolen as
well seeing as they prevented her from
sailing like her ancestors once did
while Disney has yet to confirm this fan
theory the uncanny resemblance between
these two characters speaks for itself
Rapunzel and snow-white Rapunzel and
Snow White might be very different
people but they happen to share the same
stepmother well this doesn't make them
blood related it ties them together in
more ways than one if you do believe
that the Evil Queen and Mother Gothel
are one in the same this would make the
young princesses stepsisters
last time we checked adoptive families
don't need DNA to make them legitimate
after failing to become the fairest of
them all the Evil Queen began to age as
any regular person would however this
was unacceptable
much like the Evil Queen Mother Gothel
is obsessed with beauty and youth so
much so that she harvested a unique
flower that could restore her youthful
face after finding out that her magic
flowers had been stolen and consumed
Mother Gothel kidnapped baby Rapunzel
and plotted to use her powers for the
rest of her life her evil plans came to
an end when Eugene cut off Rapunzel's
hair
therefore breaking the spell only then
do we see mother Gothel begin to take
her true form which comes in the shape
of an old wicked witch at this point the
resemblance between the Evil Queen and
Mother Gothel becomes uncanny making us
believe that they're one in the same
so although Snow White and Rapunzel have
never met they were raised by the same
evil being making them unfortunate
stepsisters Prince Erik and Prince
Phillip all Princess Ariel ever wanted
was to follow her heart which is why she
embarked on such an epic journey after
falling in love with Prince Erik from
afar she chose to strike a deal with
Ursula the sea witch your voice my voice
after exchanging her voice for a pair of
legs Ariel did everything she could to
win over her Prince's affection on their
first night together Prince Erik invited
Ariel over for supper and the couple
dined in a Great Hall while there seems
to be nothing out of the ordinary with
this scene some fans took a more
in-depth look and noticed something of
great significance on the wall of the
Great Hall is a portrait of a brown
haired man and a golden haired woman
some fans believe this couple to be none
other than Princess Aurora and Prince
Philip so why would Prince Eric have
this portrait on display if he wasn't
indeed related to the couple while
there's no way of knowing whether Erik
is related to Aurora or Philip we
believe that he is a blood relative of
one of the two while this theory is a
little far-fetched it's still very
possible
after all disney loves tying its
universes together Jane and Bell and now
the moment you've all been waiting for
so who is Jane's great-grandmother
well it's Princess Belle of course as
many of you know Disney is notorious for
placing Easter eggs in their movies and
if there's one that nearly everyone
noticed it's that the Beauty and the
Beast teacup collection can be found in
Tarzan so to get you on board with this
theory allow us to point out the obvious
for starters
both Jane and Belle have similar
features and they are both wearing a
yellow dress
secondly they both fall in love with a
man who is more beasts than human
sure Belle might be French and Jane
might be English but this tidbit could
easily be blamed on Belle's children
relocating to England during the French
Revolution with this in mind it would
make total sense for Jane to own the
beasts teacup collection after all it
was probably passed down to her from
generation to generation you know what
else was passed down to Jane her
great-grandmother's love of books so
before you head out why don't you tell
us which family Disney you love the most
make sure to comment down below and
that's a wrap thanks for watching and
see you next time
on the things
[Music]